Tenemos la ecuación, -9 menos toda esta expresión,
"9x" menos 6, -9 menos "9x" menos 6,
que es igual a 3 que multiplica a toda esta otra
expresión "4x" más 6.
Lo primero que vamos a hacer para resolver
esta ecuación es quitar los paréntesis,
realizar las multiplicaciones indicadas, aquí
aunque no aparece, es como si tuviéramos
un 1, está -1 multiplicando "9x" menos 6.
Vamos a ponerlo de hecho, y del lado derecho
3 está multiplicando a "4x" más 6,
aplicando entonces la propiedad distributiva,
¿qué tenemos?
Del lado izquierdo -9, -1 que multiplica a
"9x" menos 6, -1 por "9x" nos da "-9x" y -1
por -6, nos da más 6, 6 positivo, del lado
derecho vamos a distribuir el 3,
3 por "4x" es igual a "12x" mientras
que 3 por 6 es igual a 18, más 18.
Bien, aquí tenemos 2 términos constantes
que podemos combinar, el -9 y el 6,
aquí tenemos "12x" más 18, que no podemos combinar,
no son términos semejantes, pero del lado
izquierdo si son términos semejantes, podemos
combinar este -9 con este más 6, de tal manera que
del lado izquierdo nos queda entonces "-9x"...
"-9x" más...
veamos, sumamos -9 más 6, esto nos da -3,
entonces sería "-9x" menos 3, -9 más 6 es -3,
"-9x" menos 3 y del lado derecho se queda
igual, "12x" más 18.
Ahora, vamos a agrupar los términos en "x" de un lado y los términos constantes, del otro lado.
A mi me gusta agrupar los términos en "x"
del lado izquierdo , no es necesario que siempre
sea así, pero vamos a hacerlo en este caso,
vamos a agrupar los términos en "x" del lado izquierdo,
así es que par eliminar este "12x"
del lado derecho, voy a restar "12x"
a ambos lados de la ecuación, restando "12x" del
lado derecho y como bien sabes, también tenemos
que restar "12x" del lado izquierdo.
¿Qué nos resulta ahora?
Del lado izquierdo "-9x" menos "12x" es igual a "-21x"...
"-21x" menos 3 y eso es igual a "12x" menos
"12x" es igual a 0, se cancelan podría poner
el 0 aquí pero no es necesario que lo haga, por eso restamos "12x" para cancelar ese "12x" de arriba.
Así es que del lado derecho nos queda tan
solo este 18, es igual a 18.
Solo nos queda el 18 pues esto se canceló.
Ahora, eliminemos este -3 del lado izquierdo
para que nos queden del lado izquierdo solo
términos en "x" y del lado derecho no queden
solo términos constantes.
La mejor manera de cancelar -3 es sumarle
3 para que llegue a 0, así que sumamos 3
del lado izquierdo y sumamos 3 del lado derecho,
¿y ahora, qué tenemos?
Del lado izquierdo, solo "-21x", no hay más
términos en "x" para combinar, este -3 con
este más 3 se cancelan, ese fue el objeto
de sumar 3 a la ecuación, lo cual es igual
a 18 más 3, 18 más 3 es 21, hemos llegado
a la ecuación "-21x" igual a 21.
Queremos despejar la "x", para despejar la
"x" que está multiplicada por algo hay que
dividirla entre ese algo, por lo que para
despejar la "x" tenemos que dividir "-21x"
entre -21, y también tenemos que dividir
el lado derecho entre -21 obtenemos entonces
del lado izquierdo -21 entre -21 se cancelan
y nos queda tan solo "x" y esto es igual a
21 entre -21, nota simplemente -1, algo positivo
dividido entre sí mismo negativo, nos da
siempre -1, así que ahí tenemos nuestra
respuesta, aquí tenemos la solución.
Comprobemos la solución, para esto sustituimos el valor de "x" igual a -1 en la ecuación original.
Tenemos entonces -9, lo voy a hacer por acá...
de hecho,
voy a usar un color distinto a los que
hemos estando usando.
Tenemos -9 menos...
este -1 no estaba en la ecuación original,
está de manera implícita, 9 que multiplica
a -1, lo voy a poner entre paréntesis el -1
menos 6 y esto que es igual...
no, no, no, déjame hacer el lado izquierdo
voy a resolver primero el lado izquierdo y
lo vamos a comparar el lado derecho.
Entonces aquí tenemos -9 menos 9 por -1 es
-9 menos 6, vamos a quitar el paréntesis
menos 9 menos -9 menos 6 son -15, aquí tenemos -15,
aquí tenemos -9, déjame checar si hice bien esto,
9 y 6 son 15, al ser negativo es -15,
así está bien, tenemos -9, menos -15, esto
es lo mismo que -9 más 15, 15 menos 9 es
igual a 6, así es que al sustituir "x" igual
a -1 en el lado izquierdo de la ecuación
original obtenemos 6, veamos que obtenemos
cuando sustituimos "x" igual a -1 en el lado
derecho de la ecuación.
Lo voy a hacer en verde, tenemos 3 que multiplica
a 4 por -1 más 6 y esto nos da, 3 que multiplica
a -4 más 6, menos 4 más 6 es 2, esto es
3 por 2, que también es igual a 6.
Así es que cuando sustituimos "x" igual a
-1, en el lado izquierdo obtuvimos 6
y también cuando lo sustituimos en el
lado derecho obtuvimos 6.
Así que ésta, definitivamente es la solución.